I was thinking about the show and then
the new show judge Jerry if there was
this vision for Judge Jerry and you
being on daytime TV yeah settling
people's conflicts yes why not just
leave on the Jerry Springer Show well we
could but since I wear you know the robe
right
we don't want food to get on the road
that makes sense so they decided no they
are honestly if this thing fails it's
it's all my fault because you know
nbc/universal did everything I mean they
put us in every market in America uh-huh
they built a courtroom uh-huh I mean
they've gone all out so I have no
excuses and you just have to perform now
yeah yeah which is always a lot of
pressure do you have a bald bailiff that
beats the [ __ ] out of the defendant yeah
it was funny because when a bailiff is
Najib and he's uh he's really good he's
really smart he's in it he was an
accountant and also worked in
Corrections so he's a real good guy and
when I was interviewing you know who was
going to be the bailiff and they finally
gave me three people and interview them
and see who you're most comfortable with
and then after I did the interviews and
I liked them all but I kind of liked
this guy a little more but the producers
who are all women were sitting in the
room with me afterwards and they they
said you know who do you like I said
well they were all really good and they
all said well this Nagi he's and I'm
saying why are you guys oh he says
because they told me the show needs some
eye candy oh that's so insulting to you
that's exactly I mean why would Jerry
much I said excuse me right
do they not who do you think the guy is
sitting up on the bench if I'm not I
somebody somewhere finds you attractive
to me for 46 years right so she found
you attractive at one frankly she
doesn't see that well but I told her I'm
really takes your work she doesn't even
know I'm Jerry Springer thinks I sell
insurance
you know who'd want to be married to me
so did you think that you were done on
TV after they we were like okay we're
done with the Springer Show pretty much
I mean I'm you know on the serious note
I'm 75 and I was ready all my friends
are retired and I was ready to kind of
hang it up and then about a month six
weeks at most before the last taping of
the of the show
Shawna Boyle came into the office he's
head of sales in NBC and he came in he
says I've got this idea would you
consider doing a judge Jerry show cuz
you're a lawyer how about being a judge
and I thought you know for 12 14 seconds
yeah yeah but that's the only thing I
really have been trained to do ah I mean
my career is gone in wonderful ways and
I'm very appreciative but I've never
done anything I was trained to do it
can't be a lawyer you actually know the
law well unfortunately I graduated law
school 50 years ago yeah actually that's
true fifty-one years ago I graduated law
school and then I practiced for a bunch
of years but you know when I went back
to my old law books now so I can be up
to date they all have to do with a horse
and buggy knocking someone over you know
it's a different age today so I've had
to do a little prank there had to do a
lot of studying is like going back to to
school and being a lawyer again doing
the research I kind of enjoy that is
funny to do all of that schooling and
then your job is just [ __ ] paternity
test I took that in the third year of
law school so after after the show was
during your six weeks of okay I'm done
I'm not on TV
did you well I knew we were still the
Jerry Springer Show we'll go on forever
because
we have 5,000 episodes so it's right
lawn even new episodes that people
haven't seen oh really so the show is
still running it's just that I'm a
taping anymore because we have such a
backlog of plethora Wow catalogs how
filled with trash this country is it'll
never end yesterday this is God's truth
yesterday I went into the store to buy a
gift from my sister's birthday
and this woman who was showing me around
and suggested that I picked this item up
and then as I was leaving the store she
says she had a little bit of an accent
and she says if I can just tell you
something she she was from Uzbekistan
and she said 17 years ago her family
came over to America not in the four of
them none of them spoke English and the
first thing they they learned English by
watching my show and I said you wait I
said she says yes this God shoots she
just kept they kept watching the show
and I said why did you stay you came to
a country yeah this thing you saw was
that wouldn't that scare you and say you
know what we don't belong here would you
ever have those moments where you're
like wait the stuff that we're doing
like there are people that this is
what's shaping America for them yeah but
that that is the glib answer but the
truth is if you're a grown-up yeah
there's nothing that's ever been on the
show that you don't know already exists
I mean there in the newspapers every day
today they were in social media every
day I mean there's nothing shocking
anymore you Bay you may be shocked or
surprised that this happened to someone
you know that could be a surprise but
there is no circumstance I could tell
you about that you would say I never
knew that was possible will that happen
I mean walk down any Street in America
you know I I can go one block and I've
got 20 shows that's true yeah it's just
here's what they're all there but in
fact you were great
to get people to talk about it on
daytime TV that's the difference you're
normally like your your you know well
they're surfing on daytime TV and you
guys have always been so good at titling
the show and just putting it in the
corner oh yeah like the minute you click
on you just read the corner you're like
what the hell is going on
the person that titles your episodes and
the New York Post headline writer it's
the same person did you when you
especially I think in like the data to
the late 90s is when your show became
the cultural phenomenon that it grew to
be MTV Spring Break Yahoo yes Springer
West yeah MTV did that but that's when
that's when people started I mean I feel
like that was the beginning of canceled
culture before there was social media
that's when people were coming after you
and talking about the way that you were
shaping the youth of America you were
destroying the country is what people I
never knew and this is true I never
expected that a guest on my show would
become president I mean that I you know
if I'm angry at Trump it's only because
he took my show and brought it to the
White House I should get paid for that
you know it really is true and I was
talking to like I think one of the
people who is on like house of cards and
I was the echo for and I was like you
know house of cards is this crazy
dramatic nuts show yeah that was good
and I go are you worried in this last
season that the stuff that's going on in
the real White House and now is way
crazier than anything you could pray on
television yeah no I'm not too worried
and then nobody watched the last season
the house of cards because they got it
on the news every day yeah no that is
true and and the truth is our show
isn't shocking to anybody when you you
can't complain about our show when you
look at what the kids are doing on
social media and right just it's a it's
a different age period but the judge
show it's a real court show and what I
didn't know because I hadn't watched
these shows is these are all real cases
but that's who's gonna ask you because
the Jerry Springer Show a lot of
entertainment goes into the Jerry
Springer Show we own the story yeah but
stories are always real uh-huh it
they once they get in front of the crowd
chanting they embellish their reactions
but a fact situation is always true
right the lawyers all over that it has
to be so but on the court show yes we're
not doing the jury no I throw out before
the show starts I go out and talk with
the audience and you know that's when
the jury do stuff and then I say you
know this is a courtroom now and these
my decision has legal validity in other
words so they can't then go to a Court
of Common Pleas and appeal it right so
the decision I make really affects their
lives so I gotta be saying you know I'll
joke around a bit because I can't help
it
but when it comes time to making the
decision it has to be based on some law
and so then they they do behave I mean
they'll laugh once in awhile but it's
not the chanting stuff it's a real court
show and these people that are and this
is true of all the court shows they
don't know they're gonna be on
television
because how it works JustGive wheeled in
there they're like how is Jerry Springer
my god
when they filed the case they don't know
because what happens is we have what
they call stringers and all the shows do
and every morning they get up everyone
is assigned to two states in the Union
and they every morning they get up go to
their computer and look at every case
that has been filed in there to state
region and if it's an interesting case
they call the plaintiff and the
defendant and say would you like to have
your case adjudicated on national
television with me as the judge and if
they say yes then we find to Connecticut
and we do the case so when they're
filing a lawsuit based on something that
is going on in their life that they're
upset about they're not saying oh if I
file the suit I'm gonna get on
television it's a one-in-a-million
chance that you're gonna be called to be
on and it's really like it they wouldn't
even consider it people that are like
I'm definitely serious about this but
you goddamn right I'll take the trip to
you know my first TV credit was a court
show I was on street court with judge
mez where is that right and it was a
fake case that was fake yeah Ricky Velez
going against each other and the whole
case was Bros made up that I black out
and left Ricky with the bill
and he was suing me for the difference
you can always tell the difference
between the fake court shows in the real
court show yeah but I don't think they
even allowed to do this I will say Josh
judge Matz was pissed figured out we
were kidding like midway through and he
was livid producers oh so he didn't he
didn't know yeah yeah no brain because
legally yeah I mean just portray things
as these are real these are real cases
so with all the court shows that are out
there is there a fight between the
stringers to try to figure out who's
gonna get the best cases because you
know there are million cases filed every
day in this country yeah so no there's
no she said it was is what happened that
all the articles come out to say Judge
Judy is the highest paid person on
television and you're going what the
hell I'm Jerry Springer I need to be
behind the bench no uh well they gave me
the bench because they figured you can't
throw a bench
[Laughter]
this wasn't chairs they would never
let's do that again
that makes no I volunteer I don't you
know I can't take any more money that
trip to the bank
it is so exhausting no yeah if you're
ever looking to sponsor a you know how
to work comedian just a cup of coffee of
that do you have when you were done
shooting episodes of the Springer Show
did you start to reflect on like you
know what this is like this was a really
wild thing that happened that I didn't
even consider because I would imagine
that when you're in the thick of it even
with the court show right when you're in
the thick of it when you're filming
episodes and when like even when a
seasons done there's another season
coming up you're not necessarily
thinking about the experiences that are
happening in front of your face because
it's like okay on to the next one on the
next one yeah it's um I have two views I
mean obviously it depends on your mood
of the day I mean if you do if you're
doing shows every day obviously they're
gonna be days that your mind is kind of
elsewhere although with the talk show it
could never I could never just be
daydreaming and the reason and it's the
same with the court show but with the
talk show
I never knew what the show was about I
wasn't allowed to know so when you see
me in the audience carrying a card or
the card has on it on the names of the
guests and my job was to ask questions
that you would ask sitting at home
watching and then make jokes but I was
never allowed to know the subject matter
because that made it more authentic
otherwise I'd be faking a reaction right
I really never knew or liked leading
them and yeah so that's why in every
segment my first question always is so
what's going on and then they tell me
their story and then I try to think of
some quips during the course of it and
so that forces you to focus right of
course I mean you can't you know you're
literally creating a television show out
of nothing yeah but you have to take
this scenario yeah that's in front of
your face that's like get out there yeah
I'm gonna tell you a story and now our
interview them and you know and make
some jokes so and then the final thought
that I would do in commercial breaks
write something out and that quick yeah
but you know if you've been doing it for
27 years yes so just flows have you ever
mid show once you figured out what the
topic was have you ever just been like I
can't in good conscience do this well
the interesting part is you never know
mid show because the stories the next
guests may be different right you know
in other words the title of the show and
the things you were talking about at the
bottom of the screen that isn't done
until after the show because then they
know you know the show has a life of its
own and based on what we just did for
the last hour right then they can come
up with a title so we have to get
through the whole thing and then go what
on earth do we just do yeah what did we
dig for the writing staff yeah just sit
down lay out let you work what they
never whipped because first of all you
would expect them then to have to
memorize it which is not going to happen
or they have to read it or for prompter
and not all of them can read so you
can't you can't you know but the court
show is obviously the courtroom is like
real judge it's real I mean and you know
I can't be messing around there right do
you have any favorite
how many cases do you go through in a
day when you're filming ten cases a day
we do 35 a week so it's three and a half
days of actor and every the off week
because we tape every other week when
we're in season and in the off week
that's when they send me the 35 cases to
research so you know what you have to
research now yeah I mean it's a grown-up
job I'm joking aside it's I mean I
haven't you know when I was doing my
show it required no work on mice I just
had to try to be awake and funny but
there was no just show up yeah yeah I
loved it at 75 you're like let's turn
back on these engines yeah we can do
yeah I got a but my age I got to find
the engine yes so how did you get
yourself into a rhythm of actually at
home like doing work for these shows
when like for literally decades it's
like this it's just not part of your
routine well because a great portion of
my life I spend doing political work
right I'm working anyway and then I do
my weekly podcast which is highly
political yes and that so I'm always
doing research on that I'm always
writing for that so I'm used to kind of
working him but the TV show never was
work for me except going around and
promoting now of course the actual show
is now for everyone else on the show god
bless them they had to find the guests
and all that they really were a lot of
work goes into the show just not to work
not yours but right and they just and I
get it because obviously it's worked
their idea was no we're not gonna tell
you what the show is about
and therefore it's gonna be organic as
it's going what's great yeah pretty good
did you ever get to a place where you
were like I want to do more of this
political stuff I want people to
understand that I have a brain in my
head and that I have opinions and the
and I want that out there I can't keep
doing this stuff no am i taken seriously
over here it never was that what one
being taken seriously I mean that's just
a vanity thing so the politics to me is
like religion in other words it's
something I believe in but I knew early
on in life
I would make a living separately from
politics I see once you make a living in
politics you start compromising because
you have to win the next election to put
food on the table for your family so if
you want to keep your politics pure and
not be corrupted either intellectually
or financially then you make your living
doing something else so I had no I
thought my living would be being a
lawyer it turned out to be show business
but I've always viewed that as this is
how I make my living but my passion is
always more political right this is
gonna fund my life and allow me to take
scarcity family yes all of that but I've
never you know I always knew my TV show
was exactly what it was and I was never
fooling myself I never went around and
tell people you've got to watch this
show because it's good you know yeah
it's gonna make you rich a deep dive
into subcultures but so that you know
that's my job I'm an entertainer if I
was hired to be a truck driver I'd be
driving a truck right that wouldn't
shape what I believe politically or
philosophically or whatever has your
family ever come to you with anything
you've done on TV and gone like you
can't what are you doing you can't have
your name on this this is ridiculous
they don't know I'm Jerry Springer just
keep it I told you they think I sell
insurance here no here's a true story
with that and about you know I've been
married 46 years seven about seven years
ago I'm in the middle of you know the
Jerry Springer Show and we get a call in
the middle of the show for the executive
producer waves me over and said Mickey
just called and in all the years she's
never called me jungars you know
something oh my god you know you get a
call from home anything oh Jesus yeah so
I run to the phone I say I hope what's
going on she says oh my god I said what
she says she took off her blouse I said
what are you talking about she says I
just watched your show is this what
people are complaining about what do you
think I've been doing for 20 years she
know I had a crazy TV show but that's
not her interest and you know she's a
very private person and doesn't you know
all this showbiz stuff so she didn't
know about the VHS series too hot for TV
no I don't think she had any I
I mean I'm probably told her you know we
were making a tape and yeah you know she
wants me to be happy but you know she's
no idea I mean it was like I mean Jerry
there was a period of time where your
show I mean nudity was just it was yeah
titty was a mystery to show show for
sure yes before porn was like abundant
so there were you know you get what you
get and you don't get upset that's gotta
feel good
I'm so proud but yeah I mean because we
don't you know when we watch television
and we do but what we watch are you know
sports or cable news and you know like
we binge sometimes on suits love that
show sure what dr. Martin was some but
anyway so but if you watch but we don't
and frankly it's not aimed at people my
age I mean so it's not like oh how could
you not watch the show it's too corrupt
the youth yeah if I were in college this
is if I was in college there's no
question I would have watched my show
always tried to get tickets to the show
Craig get back that's how a 75 year old
man you know so in like will go back to
the late 90s when the too hot for TV
tapes were out and they were I mean they
were huge like they were super
successful and they would be on there
would be commercials for them all the
time if you're watching TV with the wife
and it's too hot for TV Jerry Springer
commercial comes on is that a quick
channel change like yeah let's see what
else is on no I honestly that's a great
question I don't bleep know I don't ever
remember that happening you don't know
it was never a big I mean obviously make
a new you know I had a job in television
and she you know she can see when we
walk down the street people going to we
do you know so she knows that all of
that it's just she never really not
really she never watched the show it's
not I don't I never watch the show in
other words I just started judge Jerry
now Monday yesterday right no yeah two
days ago it was the first show yeah and
I and I was back in the hotel room cuz
we're here on promotion and um it's on
here in New York at noon
jungle 11:00 12:00 and 12:30 they're
giving you a whole hour longer to reach
a decision he can't think that quickly
let's make it an hour show you so to
Jerry Springer calm by the way because
it's syndicated everywhere every market
in America that's incredible and my
other show the Jerry Springer Show
even in its heyday was never a hundred
percent of the country so this show is
on in more markets Jerry yes in America
that's incredible oh yeah and I have
nothing to do you know the sales people
god bless them but I think the reason
probably is and this is a guess is there
were sponsors that wouldn't touch my
other show which I get yes but a court
show you know you can have your kids
watch it well nobody's didn't violent
nobody yeah yeah yeah so you know you
could have some of the blue blood um
sponsors you know get in and so
therefore everyone's kind of been on it
I'm curious if the original show in 2019
had it come out right now if it would be
considered punching down oh yeah I mean
I think you know you real issues that
the original show came out now is cookie
I couldn't write not good yeah what do
you think about the increased
sensitivity I mean you've you've seen it
all in your time in energy well it's
inevitable because you we go through
cycles human behavior hasn't changed in
thousands of years anything that has
ever ever ever been on my show is
already in the Bible is already in
Shakespeare is already in great
literature so human behavior hasn't
changed at all what has changed is we
now have technology and where we used to
gather in the town square or in the
marketplace two thousand years ago and
talk about what our neighbors were doing
we still do the same thing except
because of Technology our neighborhood
is now the planet Earth so we know more
about the Kardashians than we do about
someone who lives two blocks away right
and that and so now all of a sudden
everybody is into everyone else's
business and everybody shares these same
stories through social media or
television or whatever with the world
obviously once you share this everyone
is going to have an opinion 2,000 years
ago if you told
hey such and such as sleeping with
so-and-so you know that person would
have had a response and say oh I don't
want to hear that or whatever well it's
the same thing today except today it's
on the media right that's the only thing
that's changed so we're now because all
of a sudden people are hearing all these
stories you're going to finally run into
the first reaction is gonna be oh my god
shock and then there's gun we're going
to go into the area of oh man there's
decay and finally it's not gonna be
shocking anymore and we'll be probably
less judgmental the good news is we're
now used to everything when I started my
show in 91 there were protesters outside
the studio in Cincinnati because we were
doing a show on interracial dating
protests 1991 91 I was there as a sexy
right interracial dating and then you
move forward 20 years and we have an
african-american president so who is a
product of a interracial marriage so you
know the culture has changed what was
shocking then is no longer shocking in
the good side is we've learned to accept
you know relationships with people of
different religions different ethnic
groups etc that's getting better the
negative is we at times it becomes
sleazy and bullying and that kind of
stuff so with every technology and
improvement in technology you're gonna
get new issues the good with nuclear
energy good but then you got the bomb
right and it's the same thing now you
got television you got social media
there's great stuff about social media
there's great stuff about these iPhones
you always know where your kids are or
whatever and the bad stuff is the
bullying that goes on so that is
inevitable with every age do you think
it also feeds itself meaning that you
know that now when somebody is say
outraged about something wants to
protest something wants to take
something or someone down it's not a
group of you know ten people outside of
a TV studio protesting it's you know a
hundred people on Twitter and then a
hundred more people see it and going oh
that's fun I can jump on that man way
kind of and we have to figure out a way
to handle that and one possibility will
be that we no longer react to it in
other words we have thicker skin so you
know 20 years ago if somebody said
something about you you might have been
embarrassed now and yeah like we found
out let's say about Bill Clinton and
then after a while he still became a
national hero you know it's after a
while you just don't get you know you
put things in perspective you don't
judge someone's life based on an
incident which was wrong and bad and
immoral and all that but it's not the
whole person right we so we we in a
sense as a society we grow up and we're
not outraged by everything is some
things we should be outraged about but
not everything one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM attic